episode four of loki was the most
revealing and game-changing installment
yet
the episode also had some treats in
store for marvel comics fans and
mcu diehards here are a few easter eggs
you may have missed in loki episode 4.
one of the biggest surprises to come in
episode 4 is the return of jaime
alexander as
lady siff we haven't seen the character
in the mcu since 2013's thor the dark
world
and while we suspected the missing hero
might be returning her appearance was
still shocking nonetheless
sif's cameo was brief and those
unfamiliar with norse mythology might
have missed a famous story hiding in
plain sight
when she first encounters loki siff is
holding a lock of her dark hair
she charges at loki beyond aggravated
that he cut off her tresses
and calls him pathetic and conniving in
addition to other
unpleasant words she aggressively knees
and punches him
and loki has to relive the event over
and over as he's stuck in a time loop
while it might seem like a storyline the
loki writers conjured up
they actually pulled it directly from
the two characters mythologies
in the norse myths unlike the mcu siff
is known for her long golden hair
in the myths loki cuts off sip's hair
which puts thor her husband
in a fit of rage after his brother
charges him with replacing her hair
loki travels to nedevalier where
stormbreaker was forged in infinity war
so the dwarves can create
new hair for sif out of gold which would
grow once placed on her head
we finally get a look at the time
keepers in episode 4 after their
appearances were teased with tva
sculptures throughout earlier episodes
of the series
when loki and sylvie are brought before
them to be pruned
the time keepers give them a chance to
speak we don't get much out of these
mysterious beings although their disdain
for the loki variants is obvious
with the help of hunter b15 who's had
her memories of her pre-tva life
restored by sylvie
the loki's are able to battle and defeat
their captors
and sylvie severs the head of a
timekeeper only to discover that they're
just
androids beyond disappointed loki and
sylvia are left wondering who created
the tva
marvel comics might have some answers
the timekeepers first appeared in 1979's
thor number 282 and were created by he
who remains someone unmentioned during
episode 4.
also known as him who remains or more
simply him
this mystery being was the last director
of the tva who put the timekeepers in
place to oversee the organization
originally him created the time twisters
in 1976's thorn number 243
another trio of beings who strayed from
their directive and began destroying
earth every 3000 years
in loki the time looping devices used by
the tva are known as
time twisters in an apparent nod to
these characters
or the time twister just loops you not
the furniture
while we don't know who specifically
created the tva in the world of loki
he who remains or the time twisters
might have some insight
different versions of loki are teased in
episode 2 during a briefing mobius gives
to a group of minutemen and other tva
workers before they take off to oshkosh
wisconsin
these variants are displayed on a
hologram which depicts five different
versions of the character
none of these guys however match the
four new loki's we meet in the episode
four mid-credit scene
thanks to the credits we know these
variants are boastful loki
classic loki and kid loki oh yeah there
is also a crocodile loki
classic loki sports the traditional garb
the character war when he first appeared
in 1962's journey into mystery number
85.
kid loki has a much shorter history in
the comics first appearing in 2010's
thor
number 617 this incarnation came about
after the original loki
died but he was reborn as a child who
eventually joins the young avengers
the backgrounds on our other two
variants are vague but boastful loki's
possession of a hammer could be a nod to
2020's thorn number four
in this comic thor's brother is able to
lift mjolnir while on yottenheim
loki was also able to lift mjolnir
during marvel's axis event when his
moral alignment was reversed which made
him the god of
heroism comic precedents aside boastful
loki's appearance at least hints at some
sort of confirmation that a loki variant
is worthy
as far as the crocodile goes there seems
to be no history of this character in
the comics
we've seen a frog version of thor before
aka throg the frog of thunder in 2009's
lockjaw and the pet avengers number one
and loki turns thor into a frog in thor
number 363.
so hey why not a crocodile loki
after loki gets pruned he winds up in
new york city where he meets his new
variant buddies
most of the focus in the scene is on the
new loki's and while your eyes are drawn
to a crocodile wearing gold horns
there's something major you might have
missed in the background avengers tower
previously known as stark tower is
looming in the distance
absolutely destroyed we've seen the
building take a beating before but
nothing like this the new loki's appear
to be hiding out in another apocalyptic
event
although this time it seems to have
already happened as opposed to previous
episodes when the events were imminent
avengers tower is decimated in this
timeline with its top floor balconies
obliterated as it rests on a tilt
it looks like the barn door protocol
wasn't installed on this former
superhero hangout
like it was for avengers hq in end game
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you